Today, Justice Alito continued to voice his
discontent with a Virgo Velvee Hodges.
Let me explain, all right?
So if you want the Supreme Court to hear your case,
you have to be like, hey,
Supreme Court,
where you hear my case?
Like, here are the deeds.
And the Supreme Court will usually say no,
and that's called denying certiary.
So this is about a denial of certiary
out of a case in Missouri.
But instead of just denying it,
just a. Soledo was like, um,
hold on. I just, like,
have a few things that I wanna say real quick.
The plaintiff in the case is Miss Jean Finney,
a lesbian, who sued her employer,
claiming that they discriminated against her
and retaliated against her for her sexuality.
During jury selection,
Jean Finney's
lawyer asked the judge to remove three potential jurors,
all express that they believe homosexuality is a sin,
on grounds that they could not be impartial
in this particular case.
The judge grant,
at the request,
struck the jurors,
and the state of Missouri appealed,
arguing that the jury selection process
had been discriminatory based on religious grounds.
The Pelo court sided with the lower court judge,
explaining that, no,
these jurors weren't
eliminated because they're Christians.
They were properly eliminated
because of their beliefs about homosexuality.
That would impair their ability to be impartial
in this specific case.
And at this point,
the state of Missouri petitioned for certiary
of a Supreme Court.
The Supreme Court declines to hear the case
because of a separate procedural issue,
which Justice Soledo agrees with,
but he writes separately anyways to
express his concerns.
A LEO calls the lower court's decision dangerous
and claims that
by questioning the impartiality of jurors
who literally
say that they are biased against gay people,
that is akin to the government labeling them as bigots
and treating them as such.
This is not the first time that Alito has
expressed that
he is much more concerned with homophobic individuals.
Ability to discriminate against queer people
in our public institutions
through law
with the backing of the government.
Then he is gay people's right to do
process inequality under the law.
I'm the feminist lawyer.
I'm gonna pin two other videos that I have
on the threats to a burgofow.
Ask me any questions that you have in the comments.